now uh johnny joey jones as you know him
well is a retired u.s marine uh and uh
we're very proud to have him as a fox
news contributor uh you've uh been uh
with us a great deal uh your perspective
has been key and fundamental uh after
what you've just heard from the
secretary of state what are your
feelings tonight
yeah first i want to start by saying my
thoughts and prayers and my love and and
support and everything you need is with
the families of the 13 heroes we lost
i'm easy to find if any of those
families need anything from me please
let me know i'm there to help you in any
way i can any organization that i
support or know we're here for you
secondly i'd like to say to the
thousands of people that fled
afghanistan because you helped us and
you believed in us we're here to welcome
you and anything i can do for you please
let me know and lastly i'll say for
every single veteran out there and gold
star family who bled and shed pounds of
flesh like i did for this war
i love you and i appreciate you i can't
tell you tonight that your service and
sacrifice meant what you thought it did
when you when you were there i i can't
tell you tonight that it meant that our
country would be safer i can't tell you
tonight that it meant we would search
down and kill the people that tried to
kill us because i just don't know if
that mission is accomplished but what i
can tell you is every single one of us
that bled
and and either took some feigning
breaths or even last breaths there we
did it because we knew the people to our
left and right would do it for us and if
that's what it took if it took us dying
so they would go home then by god that
was worth it so i want everyone out
there to understand that's what it was
worth it i don't know if the mission
laid out by our leaders and our
government was accomplished or even
full-heartedly attempted to be
accomplished i just don't know that i
don't trust politicians and i don't
trust this type of diplomacy any further
than i can throw it and a guy with no
legs can't throw real far but i will
tell you i believe in the men and women
i served with i believe in the in the
pureness of our intent and when a
secretary of state stands up there and
tells me that the people who killed my
brothers and took my legs can earn our
trust
well
thank god this is television news and
not just a casual conversation because
i'd have words for him nobody wants to
hear well i think i also know some
pretty harsh words which we we both are
going to keep to ourselves i can tell
you sir
this is though a reminder that
leadership matters doesn't it you know
that as a military man we know that in
life this is leadership matters we know
this is not a reflection of this country
or of our military or of the american
people and that is what is so shocking
that we are willing to make sacrifices
you you did so and everyone else is
willing to this what's shocking is none
of this had to happen this was not a
natural end to what this we all wanted
to be out of there but not like running
away uh to to cutter not running away
and and gaslighting the american people
about what is or is not happening let
alone abandoning we abandoned people
from for with an arbitrary deadline is
that how do we how do we
how do we process that what do you say
to people
i just hope the american people
understand something that's really
special about this country
blood
is the easiest currency to acquire we
offer it up freely we volunteer to serve
this military and i don't know many that
volunteered in the last 20 years that
didn't beg to go on a deployment you can
get blood real easy but the interest on
that the payment the interest on that
currency lasts a lifetime yeah because
those are broken hearts that that ripple
throughout this country and so the next
time a politician stands at that bully
pulpit and promises you something like a
war ask questions
and have consequences at the ballot box
because we know now regardless of party
yeah you can't trust them yeah and
before we send our sons and daughters we
need to know why and where they're going
yeah how they're going to get back this
is completely clearly nonpartisan i'm a
partisan for america you are as well
this is about
the human condition and and what the
greatest country on earth which we wake
up in every single day thank god is
capable of doing joey i want you to
listen to uh something from general
mackenzie with centcom
giving praise to the taliban listen to
this
the taliban have been very pregnant very
pragmatic and very business-like as we
have approached this withdrawal they
were actually very helpful and useful to
us as we close down operations
absolutely astounding these are people
who also are still there's one family at
least out there begging joe biden to get
an american back who's who was kidnapped
by the taliban over a year ago they're
still holding americans what do you make
of a man in uniform who makes a
statement like that about the enemy
um
that's um that you can say on television
that's tough i i don't know that man i
didn't as far as i know i didn't serve
under his command i don't know what
political pressure on his shoulders
but i know what it means to be a marine
i know what it means to bleed with men
and women
and to hold their hand when they're
taking their last breath and to do
everything i can everything in me if it
means walking down and leaning over a
bomb and taking a damn good guess to
keep them alive even if that means i get
blown into pieces that's okay
and i'll tell you right now i'd never
look them in the face even if the
president united states who was my boss
at the time told me to
and say some trash like that about the
people trying to kill him you can say
that you are proud of this mission we
just accomplished as far as airlifting a
hundred thousand people out of a country
that's about to go to ruin but to go so
far as to be a spin doctor for an
organization that literally tortures
people oppresses them and kills them how
dare you and how dare you ever ever look
troops in the face again and order them
into combat you don't deserve it you
just don't get to do that you don't get
to play both sides of the ball when you
put that uniform on and you ask our 18
to 19 year olds to go bleed and die for
this country even if we're smart enough
to know it's a cause that doesn't mean
anything to you and i don't mean the
general but to our politicians
even if we're smart enough to understand
the politics behind it we raise our
right hand and we do it because we do it
with honor and we do it because we love
this country and we do it because even
if it's some partisan war if it can keep
our enemy at bay for one more day that's
worth it and how dare you think that you
can lead troops and stand up there and
speak glowingly about the people who
have tried to kill us for 20 years how
just how dare you do that it is shy
listen with if you want to withdraw and
botch it turn it into an evacuation sure
and spin
on that that's okay listen i am proud of
the men and women that got everyone out
of there sure but to go so far as to
brag on the taliban that's just it's
it's betrayal is what it is it is and if
there is a point where you have to do
that or you could resign in protest
where there is this understanding about
what is appropriate what decency really
is it's hard enough with everyone who
served you and your brothers and sisters
now watching this collapse but then to
praise the people uh as they stood there
and aided al qaeda and aided bin laden
as the as we are just within a couple of
weeks of the anniversary of september
11th it is remarkable it is also sir i
think you would agree with me
unacceptable god bless you joey it is an
honor to be even remotely associated
with you
keep up the great work i know of course
prayers for you and for everyone it is
difficult but we're strong people we
know there needs to be some changes and
you're in the forefront of reminding us
why thank you sir
thank you and don't forget about those
still recovering from that bomb that
they didn't weren't killed by it we need
to pray for them yes we've got a lot
a few of our troops i know have already
been transferred here to the united
states families are asking for prayers
for the seriously injured uh and uh that
must be on our forefront of our minds as
well thank you joy hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else